hey US gun bros my name is Pippa today
we're playing a very different game it's
called sad Satan why is this game
different well I tell you basically this
game is from the Deep Web for those who
don't know Deep Web
for good reasons because it's mainly
used - it's kind of like the black
market of the internet and I don't know
but I know there's I know people tell me
I don't know you can buy passports hack
PayPal account or download sad Satan
this weird ass so yeah that's what we're
gonna do now check it out see if it's
scary and really [ __ ] creepy
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ] freaking me the [ __ ] yeah
what is going on it's really [ __ ]
creepy
gosh that's creepy this is I remember
now
I heard that the screams in the game are
actual real shrieks of terror
I really don't mind like playing this
[Music]
I can change in that person okay okay
so I did a little better research this
is really funny actually so apparently
the the guy or a girl who made this game
just did it as a publicity stunt
it's I'm not it seems like it that at
least and it seemed like it [ __ ]
worked this whole I played it I let [ __ ]
ton of but website posted about it
that's hilarious
kick chop I'm a little disappointed
because the game actually looked really
[ __ ] cool and I loved the idea of
kind of a forbidden horror game that's
awesome but oh well that's all about the
fun we'll have for today maybe one day a
game will surface from the Deep Web but
until then I'll see you both in the next
one
this is the greatest
[Music]
but in Sweden beauty in this game oh my
[ __ ] god